The business of growing up is something we
normally think comes to a close when we get
to 16 or so – and finally turn into those
fully finished products: adults. Up until
then, our growth is the subject of quite a
lot of collective fascination. Twentieth-century
psychology, beginning with the work of the
Swiss clinician Jean Piaget, pioneered an
approach to child development that meticulously
identified and labelled every principal stage
an average infant might go through on the
developmental journey of its earliest years.
Thanks to this work, we now know that at six
months, a child will be able to sit up on
its own, pick up a small object (such as a
raisin) using a thumb and forefinger and recognise
its own image in a mirror, though it will
most likely take another three months before
it can drink from a cup on its own and understand
simple requests. By two, it will start to
say ‘I’ and ‘you’ and it will probably
be able to put on a hat by itself. Around
four, one can expect it to use sentences several
words long and quite possibly invent an imaginary
friend (an achievement that belongs to what
Piaget called the Symbolic Function Substage).
Between the ages of four and seven, children
begin to grasp abstract concepts like ‘time’
and ‘a country’ but typically make mistakes
around the use of ‘less than’ and ‘more
than’. Parents, uncles, aunts and grand-parents
tend to be deeply interested in these developmental
milestones – which become the stuff of family
legend. However, after about 16, the attention
society pays to the maturation of an individual
becomes ever more coarsely grained. The focus
shifts to external, material matters: we track
what someone gets in their university degree,
what job they secure and how they progress
up the corporate hierarchy. Growing up becomes
synonymous with getting ahead. Yet, in truth,
we never stop having opportunities to grow
in an emotional – rather than material or
physical way. Perhaps between the ages of
19 and 21, without anyone really focusing
on this happening, we may radically rethink
our view of how to handle our parents’ shortcomings.
Or our view of envy takes a leap forward in
the middle of our 23rd year. Or, as we approach
33, lying in bed early one morning in a hotel,
we amend our sense of who is to blame in certain
relationship difficulties. We may look more or
less the same, but inside, slow, unheralded
moments of emotional growth can be going on.
Unfortunately, we have nothing like the clear,
detailed stages to measure ourselves against
that babies and young children enjoy – and
that might give us the encouragement we would
need to note and foster stages of growth.
Yet, every adult life contains the potential
to acquire new emotional skills, each in its own
way as significant as a child mastering a
quirk of language (in English, for instance,
saying ‘I thought rather than I thinked’)
or learning to ride a bicycle. To develop
emotionally involves a range of steps: learning
to understand and sympathise with oneself;
to take proper stock of one’s childhood
influences; to communicate flaws and eccentricities
to others in good time, to interpret others
beyond what they have directly said to us,
to recognise the hard edges of reality without
being destroyed by them, to accept one’s
needs for consolation and assistance, to achieve
a necessary degree of confidence, to know
how to despair without wholly giving up on
existence… We can imagine plotting the inner
journey like islands, each one of them marked
by settlements, which we should take the trouble
systematically to work our way around, as
we might the cities of Renaissance Italy,
or the beauty spots on the Pacific Highway.
We’d tell our friends excitedly that we’d
learnt about Emotional Translation or had
achieved excellent grades in Communication.
We might throw a party when we’d learnt
how to do Cheerful Despair. Despite misleading
external signs, we aren’t, in fact, ever
done with the tricky business of becoming
that hugely important thing: an emotionally
mature person or, to put it another, simpler way, a
real grown-up.
We love bringing you these films.
If you want to help us keep bringing you thoughtful content.
Please consider supporting us by visiting our shop, at the link on your screen now.